foreign
[Music]
so
hello
everyone hello
welcome welcome welcome
omg
hey
y'all what's goodie
welcome to hot breath live fam
this is a very special
edition of hot breath live coming to you
solo dolo
yoshi
is uh on vacation with his family he has
a family or whatever so
i normally do solo
uh q and a's on wednesday and i will do
that tomorrow
because i love you
but today we are gonna do
hot breath live let me turn this a bit
yeah there we go
gonna do the hot bread live solo dolo
today so we'll we're gonna jump
and do uh
joke feedback fam so that's we're gonna
jump right into the joke feedback today
those of you who joined us last week and
our new show format
uh with the rundown of topical things
and stuff like we said be like pti for
comedy we're definitely still doing that
and yoshi and i actually went to
um a show together sunday here in here
in atlanta
and um
hung out after till like
midnight and uh discussed a lot of what
we want to do here with this show
and i'm super excited about it
and uh today
my friends
you get me
you get me fam
so holla at your boy
tavis aikman are you in the building
saying happy tuesday everyone j lag yo
yo yo what's goodie
what's goodie
i'm so excited to jump in here with
y'all i'm just looking am i out of focus
i'm out of focus up here
back here
back here i'm really not out of focus so
i need to get
let me see if i can get this back and
focus a bit
there we go
there we go maybe that'll do the trick
and we are live on our youtube channel
and our facebook groups
on twitter june
hey y'all from kentucky
i see you out there june
hit june out here hitting the road doing
shows with the big dogs
do a show with the big dog
yeah
so how exciting so yeah thank you all
for hanging out i do we do the hot
breath live every tuesday i do the live
write 10 club every wednesday at 10 a.m
i do
a live q and a every wednesday at 5 00
pm
and this past sunday
we had the 100 joke contest finale and
the winners
podcast is now up on the podcast so nate
cosby won it and had a great interview
uh so definitely check that out he's
actually a comic
oh i think he's performing tomorrow now
that i mention it we need to set a
reminder
[Music]
boom and did y'all hear the music switch
up right when i said we need to set a
reminder
we need to set a reminder uh uh a
reminder we need to set a reminder uh
we need to set a remind ma ma and we
need to set a reminder
to like um make sure that we check in on
him and make sure that he does the show
um it's so great i was a guest on a
podcast today
and
uh the host asked me about my first time
and what it went into the preparation
and it was like
it was an interesting reminder of just
how much
prep went into that first time it was a
lot of going to open mics and studying
then a lot of studying how to write
jokes and then a lot of like
rehearsing and preparing i mean there
was a lot that went into that first time
so
it was a really good reminder of just
what all goes into it
oh teresa hey teresa
hi oh it's so good to see you teresa's
in the o.g joelivers fan club
so uh thank you so much teresa for
hanging out cindy was here last week
uh hanging out so it's good to see you
in here today teresa dave they're the
first that like bought my merch
they drove
from
alabama to chattanooga to see me
um
yeah just incredible so it's great to
see you theresa i want to do a show in
alabama i want to
y'all drove
so far to see me i want to drive to you
and do a show i just haven't um
i haven't
put one together yet
i talked to people in huntsville
the show wouldn't be till um july
um
maybe i could do one before
how many people
do y'all think
if i did a show in huntsville i know a
venue in huntsville
how many people do y'all think we could
get out there i don't know
i don't know
all right so let's get into it everyone
welcome to hot breath live
uh i'm doing joke feedback today i'm
doing joke feedback today so go ahead
and post your jokes
and um we can do a little bit of a
hybrid if you want you know i could
answer some questions as well if you
would like um
oh ed said great ed
it's good to see you
buddy but yeah i definitely i want to
get out to alabama and do
uh do a show for all out there because
y'all drove so far to see me i want to
drive to you and honestly i think i
could make it part of a tour like i did
la pre pandemic i did a tour all through
the southeast through alabama
through uh louisiana and arkansas and
texas and tennessee and came back around
you know so
i probably put together a summer tour
and do that again actually
now that we talking about it buddy i'm
going to plan that
speaking of many tours i'm coming to you
this week in richmond and maryland
i'll be coming up y'all's way
and i'll be stopping through north
carolina as well i'd like to stop
through charlotte and meet hang out with
some of the hot breath of earth as well
and um
i'll be going up to greensboro
on the way up
oh theresa said huntsville will be
awesome nice okay we will get it done
one day yes but i don't want this one
day to be
far away you know a lot of times we're
like let's do it and then you know
life is precious
i think covet taught us hey overnight
anything can change so i want to make
sure make that a priority
um
noise
where'd the music go
voom here we go
um j legs had come to a show in phoenix
i am in
let me pull up my calendar really quick
i think it's august j legg
i'm at jp comedy club in august which is
in arizona
yep that first weekend of august i'm
there headlining all weekend
um
yeah oh what's goodie zeb
hello john vorehouse as well oh my gosh
we have celebrities in the building
zeb
what's up fam what's goodie to all in
all
scale let's get some jams going as we do
some joke feedback today
so yeah feel free to post some jokes for
feedback if y'all have any questions as
well
uh or you just wanna
book me to come perform in your area
also let me know that because i am i am
open
i am open for business my friends
i am open for business
hey hey hey
so i see
oh sorry buddy i was back on uh i was in
the facebook group i'm back here on
youtube now i see your joke
so yaha school of language
i believe
thank you for sharing your joke let's
get into it thank you for posting
as people are coming in here
yep if you're just jumping in it's just
me today fam
it's just me today
we are not just me it's me today you're
welcome
you're welcome
so i'm doing joke feedback today and um
a little q a if you have any questions
uh and then i will be back tomorrow
morning don't worry to do the
joke writing contest we do every
wednesday morning and then tomorrow at 5
p.m i'll be here to do the q a as well
but today is a special hot breath live
um
yeah j leg first weekend of august so
let's get into the first joke here
and i do see sketch my story
i want to book you to come tell a
comedic story oh i would love that oh my
gosh yes
where do i need to do it at do i need to
travel somewhere to do it
um
where do you do it at
or what do i need to do yeah let's let's
let's though yeah i would love to
that sounds fun
yes i saw you did one with brad williams
here too so you have comedians coming on
here telling funny i got some funny
stories
all right
sorry sorry zoyah zoyah's like uh i
posted a joke uh and you're sitting here
rambling about how people should book
you
uh nice yeah so um
record in your studio yeah yeah send me
a send me a dm
on
uh instagram at joel buyers comedy
and let's um
yeah let's get the details i would love
to yeah that sounds fun
all right
so
here we go
first joke up
zoyah thank you for your patience
fellow hot breather
uh let's get into it here so the first
joke we're seeing up here my friends
uh i went to a yoga class that had a
native american instructor he didn't
mess around soon as he walked in he said
downward facing dog
i was confused
turns out he was just telling us his
name
oh
that's fun
that's a fun one there i think we can
work on the word economy i went to a
yoga class that had a native american
instructor
he didn't mess around as soon as he
walked in he said downward facing dog i
was confused turns out he was just
telling us his name
so i think
just for word economy here um
it could just be like
i went to a yoga class that had a native
american instructor
when he said downward facing dog
he turns out he was just telling us his
name
so it says the same thing but with less
words like that he didn't mess around
uh
not really relevant um
though you were confused
uh
it doesn't like
the confusion aspect doesn't um
it's like if so the joke is
you went to a normal yoga class taught
by native american instructors so in a
normal yoga class
if the instructor said downward facing
dog you wouldn't be confused so
to keep this
setting for lack of a better word to
keep this premise as realistic as
possible
you wouldn't be confused because it's
like oh i'm just going to yoga and the
instructor happens to be native american
and then downward facing dog just
happens to be their name so i think just
ironing out
those two little things where
i went to a yoga class that had a native
american instructor
when he said downward facing dog he was
actually just telling us his name
so then boom you're saying the same joke
just with less words and it kind of gets
to it a little bit faster
nice oh i got i got a nice little
look at that there's like a
there's a ridge in my hair
i got poof
there's a poof going on
cool
all right the music changed i guess it's
time to change jokes
oh
i hope that i hope that helps
uh zoryah i appreciate you posting and
hanging out here
as we're doing our weekly hot breath
live on tuesdays
just
uh with your boy with joel beezy today
yoshi is with family which family first
in the hot breath the verse family is
first that's why we are a family
that's also why
we in our personal lives we like to also
value family as well because it is
important so he is on a family vacation
and uh we'll just let him know that he
was not missed
[Laughter]
all
right let's get to the next joke shall
we
so i'm going to be doing some joke
feedback for you today for the next hour
and um
if y'all have any questions or
um inklings that you would like to book
me
to um come perform on your show where
you know of shows and such you know
highlight your boy
i'll be going through north carolina
this weekend
and
um i'll be up in richmond on sunday if
anyone's in richmond and i'll be in
maryland on monday and then i'll be
coming back tuesday but
between maryland and atl
if uh some of y'all are on the way back
i'd love to meet y'all i really want to
make this like a hot breath trip
so i'm stopping through north carolina
to connect with a couple um
hop brethrens i'm actually staying with
one in winston-salem ej who has um
housed me before i'm gonna be staying
with him this saturday
um
so yeah i'm just gonna make this hot
breath trip
but that being said
let's get to the next joke here so feel
free to post your jokes and questions
uh we're gonna get to the next joke here
just to um
keep the juices flowing
looks like the next one is over in our
facebook group so let me let me go over
to our facebook group
i have too many tabs open that's for
sure
uh
hiram said when am i in south florida
ah i don't know is that like the miami
area
is that what we mean by south florida
um
yeah i'd love to make a run down there
i've talked to manny before about doing
some shows down there at miami
um
yes i'd love to i think aaron
um aaron as well i did his podcast
so yeah there's definitely hot breath
versus down there it's just putting
together a run of shows honestly it's
just putting it together you know
because it is far
there's a lot of logistics
uh but yeah i would certainly be
interested
yeah yeah
i think the furthest south
i've been so far as like fort walton
beach so that's not very south when it
comes to south florida
so let's see
i believe this one's john voorhoes
have you heard about the recent spike of
syphilis cases in los angeles an
unrelated story my sister-in-law is back
on tinder
oh my heavenly day
oh
i do i did hear that um
i just got back from los angeles and um
didn't catch syphilis but did catch
coven so that was a fun that was a fun
one there
but we're back baby
congrats on the sister-in-law they're
very socialite i see
um
i believe this is zab valentine let's
get to zab
zeb
i hate you're missing the maryville show
zab i'm gonna be in maryville
next friday
yep not next friday two weeks may 13th
but you're gonna be working at the
comedy catch so it's um
understandable my man's getting booked
and working so that's cool
um let's see have you ever been so mad
you microwave a baby
this happened in my hometown a guy was
so mad at his baby crying
he microwaved her for a few seconds
at least he didn't shake the baby
he could have
don't
both
he could have done both
a little shake and bake
oh
boy that was a long way to get there zeb
oh that was a long way to get there is
that true
does that actually happen in your
hometown
it's a long way to get to a silly word
play though i think um
yeah
i think you're better than this zeb i
think you're better than this
i see what you did though
but
oh and he says true story okay
wow
um
so yeah i mean really the interesting
part is around
your hometown to be honest zeb
like the silly wordplay joke is ah
but the real interesting part
is that you're from a hometown where a
guy
microwaved a baby so
something in my uh
writing master class
that people really seem to gravitate
towards is like the if then exercise so
it's like
if this is true
then what else is true
or if this happened then what else
happened so for this
if someone in your hometown
is microwaving babies
then what else are they doing
in your hometown
or then what else are they doing with
their microwavable food if this is if
this is what they do with their children
then what do they do with their pets
you know so
maybe ask yourself that more
because the interesting part that
strikes me is really wherever you're
from
they're microwaving babies
and i don't know how many people can say
that so as we talk about here in finding
your voice
and writing from personal true places
i don't know how many other people can
talk about being from somewhere they
microwave babies so i would talk more
about your hometown that sounds super
interesting zeb
uh and it'll go a lot farther than like
a silly wordplay joke
just to keep it a bean yeah i mean
thanks for posting i hope that helped
zeb
but zeb said the baby was okay in case
anyone wants to flag this video over on
the hot breath first they're talking
about microwaving babies
noise
noise noise noise
all right let's get to the next one here
thank y'all so much for hanging out oh
my gosh this is so cool
i love y'all so much
and i did a live q and a with ben palmer
yesterday he's uh he's a social media
comedian but near and dear friend of
mine we came up in the trenches of
atlanta together and now he has almost
three million followers on tick tock
and he's going on sold out tours around
the country
he does like it's called pawn he's
called palmer trolls his name is ben
palmer
and we had the realest of the realest
conversation i may have ever had on this
podcast and it's it's on the youtube
channel now the podcast will be released
in a couple weeks
but
it's
yeah it was one of the most authentic
personal conversations i've had on the
show it's really cool just to see a
really near and dear friend
that you grinded with early on
out here popping popping popping yeah i
mean so and he's been a fan of the
podcast for years he used to send me
messages about
he'd be an uber driver and he'd be
playing hot breath while he's an uber
driver and stuff so this is really cool
really cool to see happen
and you know what else is cool
vavoom
looky here
let me hit you with a little air horn
yeah
thank you so much sketch my story sketch
my story
just hit your boy
with a little super chat
there's a little super chat air horn for
you thank you so much sketch my story
that is so nice just a little love for
what you're doing here oh
thank you so much and
my wife thanks you as well
yeah man every little bit helps here as
we do these live streams
three times a week sometimes four times
a week when we're doing the 100 joke
contest in addition to the weekly
podcast in addition to the extra
educational clips in addition to the
facebook group
i appreciate that love thank you so much
sketch my story that just makes my heart
smile
govia comedy watching from trinidad
let's go
let's go that's so dope
[Applause]
great to see you all the way from
trinidad
wow we are global we're like pitbull out
here mr worldwide fam
how cool
thank you so much for hanging out i'm
doing q a but i'm also doing joke
feedback as well so if you guys post
your jokes
i'll be happy to give you some feedback
on it just be sure to put joke
in front of it like my man tavis here
did he put the word joke in front of it
so i know to read it as a joke
and um
again thank you sketch my story for that
awesome super chat
five dollar holla shoddy i'm about to be
i'm about to be making minimum wage here
y'all five dollars an hour
that ain't that bad
awesome
so tavis
let's get to tavis tavis here like air
week
i'll never forget
i talked about catching coven in la and
i had to quarantine in a hotel room
um
and uh
we still did this show and i had coveted
i was in a hotel room in bed with covert
doing this and i was about to pass out
from
you know being pandemic sick and then
tavis said a joke that brought me back
to life so i'll never forget that tavis
resuscitated me from the depths of covet
with his humor
not to build up this one
to be something that may not every joke
is different but
we shall see
so
my mom hoards the mail she reads letters
today that are over a decade old
they all say she's an unfit mother i was
mad how can you do that to someone
how can you read my letters to santa
all right
i see i still need to reread it again my
add was literally
thinking
in like another direction
i was trying to get ahead of the joke
and then i went down a wormhole of 80d
so here we go
my mom hoards the mail she reads letters
today that are over a decade old they
all say she's an unfit mother
i was mad
how can you do that to someone how can
you read my letters to santa okay
great misdirect here i think we can just
tighten it up a little bit tavis
so my mom hoards the mail oh excuse me
that super chat from steve
just
just covered up your joke for a second i
don't know if you saw that super chat
coming in from steve but we appreciate
you
peppa
thank you so much steve we need like
we need like explosions going off i need
to figure out how i can do explosions
and
when people do super chats thank you so
much
hilarious steve said please bring back
yoshi he's your peanut butter to your
jam oh do you not like me steve
steve steve paid to then roast me i
guess is what he was doing there
it's all good sketch my story did a
super chat just out of gratitude
uh
steve did it out of gra of out of
gratitude
that hopefully yoshi comes back
yep yoshi's on a family trip so he'll be
back
and he'll probably be holding it down
next week actually because i'm we'll
know
i'll be on the road next week coming
back from maryland but
i could probably do it for my car or
something we'll figure that part out
we'll figure that part out i'd still
like to do it
but we'll figure that part out
um
tavis says always happy to see the yoshi
love here
well thanks maybe we won't finish
talking about your joke tavis hmm
but yeah thank y'all for the super chat
steve and sketch my story
all that helps for sure it helps keep
the lights on here it helps keep this
show
growing and another thing that helps is
if you haven't already
uh subscribe to this youtube channel
so i'll be curious i'm curious to know
who has um
who has joined
okay let me finish tavis's joke here so
i think we can just tighten this up a
little bit tavis
um
instead of my mom hoards the mail maybe
something more like
uh my mom is so nosy she recently read
letters
she recently led
maybe um one of my letters
that says she's an unfit mother
i was mad
how can you read my letters to santa oh
but i see the hordes of the mail
i see we're going with the misdirect i
think we just need to get to it quicker
um hoards the mail
she
she read letters today that are over a
decade old
it could just be my mom hoards the mail
she recently read one of my letters that
said she's an unfit mother
how dare she read my letters to santa
so there we go so i think we still got
to it that way just in less words you
know
um that don't mention why yoshi isn't
here
for anyone curious yoshi is with his
family but i'm with my hot breath family
here
right
nice
nice indeed yes you get the live
notifications because of subscribing as
well that's right
that's right
nice yeah and i just started a poll just
curious
um and i did paint a link in the youtube
live chat
for anyone
uh curious about checking out any of the
classes and workshops we have
just to make it easier for you to check
those out but yeah so far everyone has
subscribed so exciting
and let's keep it going nicely done
there
nosler done now travis
next joke
samuel
i wish i was a magician you never have
to worry about money ever again all you
need is a friend
with really big ears
oh
okay
that's a little silly goosery that's a
little silly goosey there i see you
all you need is a friend with really big
ears so you can keep pulling um
pulling it out from behind their ears
okay
wish i was a magician you never have to
worry about money again
all you need is a friend
with really big ears i mean honestly all
i would say is
just keep it i so you say i and then you
never and then you need so just make it
i wish i was a magician i'd never have
to worry about money again
all i'd need is a friend with really big
ears
and there you go
well done samuel that's a fun one nice
and silly you silly goose
yeehaw
all right
nice tony baloney said he he subscribed
he has subscribed to the channel much
preached fam yeah we trying to hit 20 20
20 thou 20 thou
fam fam we're almost there we're at 19.7
um
hilarious tony said if one of your
hecklers makes a youtube channel we call
it listerine hilarious
if you ain't got any haters you ain't
poppin poppin that's what what's that's
what they say
um
where'd it go i saw one
let me see here
j leg
uh i'm a gay guy who drives a prius
just yesterday a dude pulled alongside
of me and called me a mother effer i
said excuse me you see that rainbow
sticker that makes me a father effer
okay
i mean i don't hate it mother effer
father effort
don't hate it
i don't hate that to be honest i think
as long as you
make sure to pause
before a father effort
and the more
angry you can get of like excuse me you
see that rainbow sticker
i'm not a mother effort i'm a father
effort or something like that you know
but i think the more angry you can get
setting up
the assumption that you're angry and mad
at this person gonna say something
hurtful or aggressive and then it's
something so like i'm a father effort
i like it though j legg i'm with it fam
i'm with it
what's up fresh out of bed good to see
you
good to see you
we out here we still doing it shouty
yoshi's on family vacay we still out you
um
junebug here's june bugs joke my high
school
home eck teacher gave me an f
for driving off with my flower
sack baby on the roof of my car
if the point was to prove we weren't
ready for children
that had to be worth an a uh
i think um
i really like this um
i think
just the punch line can maybe have a
little more oomph
that it's like if the point was to prove
we weren't ready for children i deserved
an a
so you see it goes from that had to be
worth and a
seven words to
i deserved an a that's three words i
deserved an a that's four words
but every word counts you know so if the
point was to prove
we weren't ready for children i deserved
an a so it just you can see when you say
it it just
punches harder than that had to be worth
an a
i deserved an a you know it just has a
little more umph to it but that's really
funny that sounds true as
well oh
but i hope that helps there does that
help junebug
does that help
that's a goodie though i will say that
is a goodie
hey
hey if y'all know any
if any of you are music producers
or um
and y'all just wanna
you know
submit some music
to uh like for me to play in the
background basically the music i play
right now was from a friend
who um gave me a bunch of music back in
the disney and i just kind of play it as
background music but if y'all have some
music you're all i'm gonna play hey
i'd be happy to play it if it's the
right vibe and um
shout you out of course too
um
next joke
n
next joke n
next joke actually
this is a good question here from pack a
punch
how to deal with jealousy in the comedy
business
the thing that's helped me the most
is to just focus on what i can control
you know so
it probably took me seven or eight years
into comedy
to realize
oh
whether or not that
club responds to my email is out of my
control all i control is that i sent the
email
um oh this booker never puts me on their
shows or such and such or so and so got
this cool opportunity that i wanted
things like that are all out of your
control what you can control is
how much you're writing
uh if you want to get booked on more
shows and you're not yet start your own
show starting your own show is a great
way to not only get
reps on the business side of comedy but
also reps on stage as a host which is
your
best way to develop faster
hosting
is like the best way to develop stage
presence faster and getting more
conversational on stage hosting just
forces you
to learn how to create
quicker connections with an audience
because as the host your job is to
create
a connection with the audience to create
an expectation for the show it's not
necessarily to even kill
it's literally just to set the
expectation for the show set the tone
for the show and get the audience used
to hearing someone talking to them from
a stage that's really
the job of a host to just set a good
environment for the show now yes you
want to be funny
but it's not you won't your job isn't
just to go up there and just kill as
hard as possible it's really to create
as an authentic
connection with the audience as possible
so it sets up the other comics to have a
very receptive and open listening
audience
so
say that to say
when it comes to jealousy in the comedy
business any jealousy
usually stems from something completely
out of your control and a lot of the
times
i've been guilty of this
i will
find jealousy
a good distraction from productivity
so instead of me
um focusing on what i can control and
what i have going on it's very easy to
complain
and get jealous of others and look at
what they're doing
because it takes the pressure off of you
knowing that you could be doing more
so really it all comes down
focus on what you can control and all
else will take care of itself
pack a punch
pack a punch does that help
does that help fam
let me know
and we're gonna keep the jokes of
flowing fam so the next
joke
great question though pack a punch i was
just talking about today on the podcast
um i was being a guest on a podcast and
we brought this up as well it was very
cool
oh ab he agrees
good i'm happy to hear that abby
next joke
where are we at
hilarious tony said if someone suffers
from
multiple personality disorder and they
subscribe to your channel shouldn't it
count as more than one subscriber
oh i wish it did because being in the
comedy game
i'm sure there's a lot of people
who um
suffer from that who are subscribed to
this channel
oh
we're like the island of misfit toys out
here uh tony said i'm such a conspiracy
theorist i believe the sun is flat all
right that's a nice silly joke
nice little silly joke there
i don't really see that one to like that
feels like a tweet or something that
doesn't really feel like when you'd be
doing on stage but um
still silly
fresh out of bed
here we go fam
i wish my wife was more like a
smartphone i mean i love my wife and all
but at least siri turns on whenever i
want her to
oh my heavens
oh
wow
uh wish my wife was more like a
smartphone i mean i love my wife but at
least siri turns on whenever i want her
to
um
whenever i want her to
i wish my wife was more like a
smartphone
maybe it's like my ideal wife would be
siri
because she turns on whenever i want her
to
or
just for edling's sake here i wish my
wife was more like siri
she would turn on whenever i want her to
and it just edits it down a little bit
and uh just gets to the punch quicker
yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
cool beans
let's get to the next in here
all right we got a few more minutes here
so i'm doing some joke feedback for you
here on today's hot breath live and um a
little q a action i'll be back tomorrow
at 5 p.m don't worry y'all don't worry
y'all
i'll be back at 5 p.m
tomorrow right here on this channel
doing a live q a i do every week
and tomorrow at 10 a.m don't worry i'll
be here
doing
the right tin club i do it every single
wednesday we get a random word we write
new jokes i give you feedback on them
and we vote to see who wins joke of the
day
have you heard this week's podcast by
the way with the winner
of this month's 100 joke contest
it's a goodie
just saying
it's a goodie in the hoodie and this is
from the perspective of a new
um
comedian who hasn't done comedy yet nate
is doing his first show tomorrow which i
need to post in the facebook group about
to remind us to show him some support
and love as he does his first show
tomorrow
but it's a good one to listen to for
sure
um let's see next
joke
hey
let's see next joke
oh looks like steve oh well oh no
steve's sharing feedback oh
how nice look at y'all sharing feedback
with each other in the chat i love
seeing that
nice
very cool
um looks like we have a question here
from
uh abby
i find myself
prone to doing observational comedy but
doesn't always hit hard so just thinking
how to be better
how to better that any suggestions
convert observational joke to setup
punch format
well
when it comes to setup punch format you
can make observational jokes
in a setup punch format
setup punch is just a joke structure so
at the base of it
you're setting up
the audience
to think in one direction
and then the punch line
creates a surprising second direction
so
actually abby if you have an example of
a joke um i'd be happy to see if we
could
work how to make that a little more um
set up punch format because
it doesn't matter what you're talking
about or whatever style
setup punch is a joke structure so just
look at it as
set up you're setting up the audience to
think in one direction and then the
punch line creates a surprising second
direction a surprising misdirect
so when i one example i use in our
comedy writing master class is
with my own personal joke
that i married a woman with tattoos
because she's comfortable with permanent
mistakes
so
in the setup punch structure
the setup is i married a woman with
tattoos okay so what am i setting up the
audience to think there
i'm setting the audience up to think
i'm happily married i'm setting up the
audience to think
uh i'm telling the truth his my wife
does have a tattoo i'm saying at the
audience to think
i
love tattoos i think they're sexy i
think they're endearing which is why i
married a woman with a tattoo
but the surprising misdirect
is the permanent mistakes it's not that
i love tattoos or even love being
married it's actually
that
both of them are permanent mistakes so
you see the misdirecting action there
setting up the audience to think one way
and then surprising them with a second
misdirect a second way
so that should help you at least get a
little more grasp of
the one-liner and actually
just recently dropped uh the newest
workshop i've done is called five steps
to funny and that actually takes you
through
the process of creating
a one-liner it's like five steps to
funny how to transform an idea into a
joke in five steps
and this is something i've learned and
the technique i've learned from just
doing comedy over 12 years from
interviewing over 400 comedians and from
reading basically every comedy book
under the sun this is what i have
distilled all that into here are five
steps for how you can write a one-liner
joke
and it works i mean i
i workshop this
this system
for months before actually releasing it
as a workshop you know i tried it out
i workshopped it with some comedians
given they're getting their feedback on
what's working what's not working what's
confusing what's not and really distill
it into like a really
exciting
uh easier way to write jokes i gotta say
and that's that's in the link pinned in
um
that's in the link pinned
that's in the link pinned in the youtube
live chat
but since you're in the facebook group
my friend
i am
i'll share that link with you
as well my friend
but i hope that breakdown helps you know
that gives you a nice baseline
description of what
what's popping with one liners there
yeah i just shared that in the facebook
group with you it's called five steps to
funny
so let me see it's 554 let me make sure
um
oh sean said can you share that link
with me absolutely there sean
tell you what i'll just share it
right there in the live chat for anyone
interested
do you see that sean
[Music]
if anyone else yeah let me know if
you're not seeing it
beautiful okay
oh and let me see ab he said um
absolutely you're very welcome there
sean
no problemo fam
um
all right we got five minutes left let
me see here this is the joke i was
struggling with when did we
wake up and decide coffee is the
national beverage of choice in the
mornings tea is not enough caffeine
and red bull is too much
i guess i can bring it up here
and
boom there we go
um today
uh when did we wake up
and decide coffee is a national beverage
of choice in the mornings tea is not
enough and caf
caffeine and red bull is too much then
we felt they need to decaffeinate coffee
which defeats the whole purpose the rich
kids want half caffeinated coffee from
nespresso because regular coffee is not
enough
we've innovated the most mundane drink
why
so all jokes um
start with a premise here so
what is the premise of this joke if you
guys are ever working on a joke
and it's not working or you don't know
the direction to take it ask yourself
what is the premise and i talk about
this in that workshop but
the premise is essentially like
what is the message of your story of
your joke if you were to boil this joke
down to a single phrase or sentence
what are you trying to say here and then
you can start to
organize and design the joke based
around that premise the premise is
really like the nucleus of your
joke that's where all the energy is
coming from
and i remember hearing chris rock say a
lot of times if the audience doesn't get
your joke it's because they don't
understand the premise
so right now
what we're seeing here abby is
it's a it's a broad observation about
caffeinated beverages and what's
happening with them so we need to dial
it down into like what is your
opinion
about
caffeinated beverages specifically or as
opinions about specific
a singular single specific caffeinated
beverage
and you know a premise a lot of times it
can be like a more of a broad statement
or the best ones are ones where there's
like an emotional attachment to it or
there's an emotional
opinion attached to it so
it angers me there's so many caffeinated
beverages or you know just something you
can have emotion behind because that
emotion creates the connection with the
audience
so right now it is this is like you have
a lot going on here it's like a broad
stroke
here's all my observations about
caffeinated beverages
now i would challenge you to eat this
one elephant at a time
and pick a beverage and make
a singular setup punch about it
so national beverage choice in the
mornings tea is not enough caffeine red
bull is too much
the caffeinated coffee which defeats the
whole purpose i mean i'm sure you can
see by just reading this abby that it
it is more just like a like an
observational paragraph
so
go back
and pick maybe one beverage you know and
see how you can create a set up punch
around that
you know because you're all over the
place wrench rich kids half caffeinated
nespresso
you know what i hope you find direction
here as well
your personal relationship with caffeine
always i'm always challenging comics to
get more and more personal
so what is your personal relationship
with caffeine you're talking about the
rich kids you're talking about tea and
red bull and decaf coffee but what is
your experience
with caffeine what is your opinion of
these caffeinated beverages personalize
it to make it about ab he and your
relationship with caffeine in these
beverages it's gonna get a lot more
personal and it's getting a lot more
funny so
thanks for sharing that though abby
great stuff there my friend
hey
uh
hey hey man y'all are so dope thank
y'all so much for
jumping in here today even though yoshi
wasn't here
i really do appreciate y'all taking your
time
and your precious love
and energy and sharing it here with the
hot breath versus we are for comics by
comics
so based on the poll i posted on youtube
it looks like everyone watching
has indeed
um
subscribed to the channel that is
watching this and i appreciate that
thank you sketch my story and steve for
those fun super chats
um and i see some people posting
multiple jokes i only get to wanted one
joke just for the sake of time and such
we can get to others
govia
from trinidad i almost missed your joke
my friend let me do this let me do
gobias really quick
uh as i see you snuck it in here my
friend i want to make sure we get you
some feedback here so gobias oh it got
flagged that's why
it got flagged by youtube so let's make
sure i can read it um
santa claus is divorcing miss claus
apparently she called him during
christmas and caught him calling all his
ho ho hos
who knew santa was a pimp
he really has a merry christmas all
right
i like it
santa claus divorcing
miss claus apparently she caught him
during i think it's just mrs claus is
divorcing santa claus because he was the
one cheating
um
so yeah
mrs claus divorcing santa claus did you
hear
santa claus is getting a divorce
ms claus caught him
with his ho ho hos
turns out he was a pimp
you know or it turns out santa's
workshop was a brothel something like
that
thanks for sharing though man all the
way
from trinidad yo
we out here shouty i appreciate y'all so
much
that's what's poppin
so y'all are awesome you know it you're
in the hot breath verse and um
i love you all so much tomorrow i'll be
back live here at 10 a.m eastern time
doing the live write 10 club where we
post a new word and we all write a new
joke together and then i give feedback
on those and then we vote for joke with
the day
then tomorrow at 5 pm eastern time i'll
be back on here doing a live q a so
come on back everyone
but uh thank you joan thank you for
doing this joel lots of good jokes and
feedback thanks for hanging out joan
oh
thank you
and sketch my story loving this
community absolutely i love y'all and
anything i can do to help
that's what we're doing here my friends
so
tell somebody that knows somebody you're
out you're out in your comedy scenes
you're out in other
comedy communities on facebook or
whatnot
tell them about hot breath you're
listening another podcast or you're on
another podcast tell them about hot
breath we've gotten this far together
and we're gonna revolutionize comedy
together and it starts literally
one comic at a time if you just tell one
comic about hot breath it's gonna spread
one more
to global
domination
thank you dino dino said thanks joel
nice session fresh out of bed thanks
joel
thank y'all so much i love y'all so much
and if you want more of me go check out
that q a i did with ben palmer that's on
the youtube channel
bruh
the sauce boss
the podcast i did today they were asking
me about the best comedy education
resources and i was like i mean
i can't even lie fam
it's what we do in here it's hot breath
i don't
there's no competition yes did i see
another comedy instructor now doing a
hundred dollar joke contest i did have i
seen other comedy instructors start
teaching workshops on how to teach
how to write a joke in just 10 minutes i
have
and i love it and i embrace it
because they ain't got this
and i love you all for that
so what we're doing here is very special
and i'm so excited that y'all are a part
of it
so anything i can do to help feel free
to reach out
and just share this
go forth
share hot breath
with one comedian tonight
and i'll see you tomorrow morning at 10
a.m
um and that's it
i love you all
we'll see y'all tomorrow morning
everyone alrighty
i ain't tripping shouty
all right i gotta go because
i'm i'm gone
all this weekend and part of next week
so i gotta go do family time this week
to
get that quality time in before i'm gone
for a little while so i'm gonna go do
that
i love you all
and we'll see you tomorrow morning
bye y'all
have a good night out there y'all thanks
for hanging out
[Music]